Welcome back. Let's take a little time to explore some sequencer fundamentals.
First up, some core concepts.
So what is sequencer? Simply put, it's Unreal Engine's non-linear editor and animation assembly
tool designed to supply users with the production tools they'll need to produce animation, trigger
various events like blueprints code, and smoothly transition between gameplay and linear animated
content.
Sequencer is commonly deployed to build shots, generate pre-visualization, manage animation
in Unreal, and construct film sequences and game cinematics.
From a workflow perspective, sequencer leverages actors on the level and gives them a set of
instructions. But as the director, you must cast which actors are going to be used. Actors
can be added to sequencer through the Outliner or Content Browser to create level sequence
assemblies. A level sequence assembly is essentially a populated level sequence.
So what's a level sequence? Essentially, it's a virtual data container. It stores various
actors and their associated attributes, keyframe data, lights, cameras, and other edit information.
Level sequences can also contain other level sequences to create nested hierarchies capable
of replicating film sequences, shots, and departmental organization. They're represented
in the level as a traditional clapboard icon, and in sequencer itself, level sequences are
represented as traditional film strips similar to what you'd see in a non-linear editing
application like Adobe Premiere.
Speaking of non-linear editors, sequencer is also capable of exporting edit decision lists
and XLM data to synchronize sequencer and your third-party non-linear editor together.
As you begin your journey into creating content and Unreal, one of the first concepts you'll
need to learn is the idea of actor persistence within your environment, or in Unreal what
we call the level or sub-level. Essentially, Unreal has three different ways actors can
be controlled in sequencer. This control determines when actors are available to the animator
for animating and how long they'll persist in the level over time. Today, we're going
to primarily examine two forms of persistence, possessibles and spawnable actors.
Possessible actors persist in the level indefinitely and can be controlled or shared by multiple
level sequences. If you know you have specific actors or characters that will be used regularly,
keeping them as possessibles makes sense for ease of access and repetitious use. It should
be noted, however, that possessible characters can only be controlled by one level sequence
at a time. Spawnable actors only exist within the active level sequence. They're identified
in sequencer and the outliner by a lightning bolt icon. This type of persistence is excellent
for temporary actors who are needed for specific needs within the shot. Perhaps some extra
lights or a background actor who shows up just for that shot and then is no longer needed.
The idea of the spawnable is appealing because it can keep your level and its environment
free of unnecessary actors when they're no longer needed. The last type of persistence
is replaceable actors. This is a blueprint-driven form of persistence and it's dictated by
the binding lifetime track and it allows you to swap out actors within sequencer as needed.
So let's switch over to the engine and take a look at how these concepts work.
Alright, if you haven't loaded SEQ-10501's map, go ahead and do so at this time. And
when you do, you'll find that this level has a number of actors in it. We have a road,
a road sign, a fence, some trees, and even a motorcycle. Anything that's been placed
into this level has the potential of becoming a possessible actor if it's brought into
sequencer. Whatever it is, sequencer can possess that actor and give it instructions beyond
the actor's original attributes when in this level. Once the level sequence is done with
it, the possessible actor returns to its default state as it originally was within the level.
So take this road sign, for example. In the level, it's located in a very specific place.
I can take this level actor and bring it into sequencer as a possessible, so let's do that.
We'll go to content, we'll create cinematics, level sequence, and we'll call this LS test.
Double click on the icon and you'll bring up the sequencer UI. Now what I'm going to do is I'm
going to add a shot track. Now I'm getting a little bit ahead of myself in that the shot track is a
little bit more of an advanced concept. It allows you to nest level sequences inside of a level
sequence. I'm going to show it to you for the sake of understanding persistence. So I'm going to
click on the button and say create new shot. This will be called shot 1001 and I'll click save.
Now you'll get this film strip looking thing here inside of the level sequence. This represents the
level sequence shot 0010 underscore 01. And I'm going to retime this level sequence, trim it down
a little bit, make it a certain length. And then I'm going to press the shot button again and
create another shot. This one will call shot 20. Again, I'm going to retime this and put it later
in the LS test level sequences timeline. Alright, so these two level sequences now exist, but they're
currently empty. There's nothing in them. So if I were to basically double click on this level
sequence, we'll enter it and you can see there's nothing in here. But I'm going to take the road
sign. I'm going to add it actor to sequencer. And now it is going to be able to be possessed by this
level sequence. And I'm going to give it a set of instructions of what I want it to do. So in this
particular case, all I want to do is just push it down into the ground. And if I go back to level
sequence test, as long as my time marker is in this level sequence, the road sign will be down in
the ground. But if I go outside of this level sequence, it'll return back to its default position.
Alright, so let's go over to shot 20. And if I double click on this, take the road side again,
and add it to this level sequence. I'm going to do something different. So I'm going to basically
give it some animation. I'll move it to the middle of the road. I'll rotate it 180 degrees. And I'll
set a keyframe. Alright, and then I'll move the time marker down. And I'll push the road sign down
the road and set another keyframe. So now I have some animation. So when I go back to level sequence
test, these two level sequences now have active components in it. And it will possess this road
sign to tell it what to do. So here we are in shot 20, it's animating. In shot 10, it's pushed down
into the ground. So if I move these level sequences into an order that I want. And I press play,
we'll see what happens. Down, default, down the road. Now, these level sequences can be shuffled. I
can move them into a different order. I could place shot 20 first. And we'll go down the road
first, go back to default, and then go down into the ground. The other thing about these level
sequences is whatever level sequence is on top takes priority. So in this particular instance,
the level sequence shot 20 may be animating it down the road. But as soon as it hits shot 10,
it will jump down and be pushed into the ground. So this is how possessibles work. The level sequence
basically possesses the level actor and gives it a set of instructions on what to do. Now, let's take
a look at something different. If we go into courses, Seq 105.01 and go to course topics,
camera cuts, and we load the Seq Sync cam example level sequence. Immediately, you're going to see
that we get a mani and two sync cameras. Now, where did they come from? Well, if you look down in
Sequencer, you can see that they have the lightning bolt icon next to them. This means that they're
spawnable. And in this case, for this level sequence, they've been spawned into existence. And
they're here to do whatever it is they're going to do. For mani's case, he's going to animate,
walk towards the sign. And these cameras have some specific camera blends that are happening,
which we'll see soon in a minute. So this level sequence, let's see what happens when we put
this level sequence into another level sequence. Let's go back to the content browser. We'll go
and load the LS test. And we'll get rid of these two level sequences. And in this case, we'll add
the Seq Sync cam example. Now, here is that level sequence as if it were a shot. And if I move my
time marker, there's nothing in this level that I see so far. But as I move, and it hits that level
sequence, mani and the two synic cameras are spawned into this level. And they'll remain there
until this level sequence is complete. And then they'll just go away. Now this can be at a big
advantage in the sense that spawnables can keep my level free of clutter. And they are good for
adding in actors or extra lights or extra cameras, as you need them for the specific shot. So they
can be a big advantage that way. All right, so this concludes this particular demonstration of
what a possessible is and what a spawnable is. We're going to move on now to our next module,
which is going to be on core structures within Unreal Sequencer.